le 25 juin 2020 vous êtes en campagne
pour votre réélection à la mairie de
paris redoutable candidat
surtout pas gelé dit très précisément je
considère qu'un endroit où on peut à g
aujourd'hui c'est un endroit très
stratégique c'est celui des villes si
vous avez dit jamais je n'ai jamais et
je ce n'est pas un reniement je n'ai pas
grandi en me disant je serai présidente
de la république un jour où je serai
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
qui fait à un moment donné vous vous
dites je ne peux pas rester simplement à
regarder ce qui va se passer dans cette
présidentielle si le parti socialiste la
gauche républicaine et européennes que
j'incarne dans cette élection n'avait
pas été candidate alors là c'est l
effacement et la disparition totale
[Musique]